they say real developers like curves and
personally i love myself a curvaceous
website where each content section
transitions elegantly with some waves
blobs or ripples in today's beginner
friendly tutorial you'll learn how to
turn your flat boring design into a
beautiful curvy one that will turn
people's heads we'll start with a basic
html homepage that has a hero at the top
a few content sections and a footer at
the bottom then you'll learn a variety
of techniques to add curves to these
elements like css border radius svg
backgrounds and we'll even make some
animated morphing blobs with javascript
that may seem complicated but it's
actually much easier than it looks
because there's some amazing tools out
there that can make our lives much
easier that you've probably never heard
of and i'll show you a bunch of cool
productivity and css tips along the way
if you're new here like and subscribe
and follow along with the full written
tutorial on fire ship io to get started
with this project all you need to do is
open up an editor like vs code and
create a plain html file inside that
file type in exclamation point followed
by tab to generate some initial html
boilerplate that's called an emmet
snippet and it's built into vs code and
we can actually use it to generate a
bunch of sections of content as well in
this demo we have eight sections of
content so we'll type section times
eight then a right angle bracket to add
a child to that element which in this
case will be an h1 with a text of nice
curves notice how i have it wrapped in
parentheses because after that i have a
plus sign to add a child next to the h1
which itself will be a paragraph with
some dummy text inside of it now go
ahead and hit tab and emit will
automatically generate all that html for
you and now that we have a basic html
page let's go ahead and serve it in the
browser here's a little trick to
gracefully serve your app locally open
up the command line and if you have
node.js installed on your machine you
can run npx serve that'll link you to
localhost 5000 where you should now be
able to see the website and if you don't
have node.js installed you can just copy
the path to the html file and paste it
into your browser currently the website
looks terrible so let's go to google
fonts to improve it with a custom font
select any font you want and it will
provide an html snippet that can be
pasted into the head of the document
then right below that i'm opening up a
style tag where we'll define all of the
css styles for this project let's start
by targeting the body of the content and
setting its margin to zero then we'll
define our font family as the one we
selected from google font the text color
will be light and the background will be
something dark from there we can target
the section element which represents a
block of content in the webpage you'll
notice i'm setting the position to
relative this won't change the
appearance of it but it allows its
children to be absolutely positioned
within it which is something that will
come into play later as we position our
backgrounds then after that we can use
css flexbox to make it a flexible
container allowing us to easily center
the content in each section here's a
little side tip when working with
flexbox in the browser right click and
choose inspect element that'll bring up
the browser dev tools and you'll notice
buttons here that you can click to
change the actual properties on flexbox
without having to memorize all the
different properties available in css
then after that we can give each section
a minimum height of 400 pixels and for
padding i'll add a hundred pixels to the
top and bottom and for the left and
right i'll use a flexible unit called
view width that will give me twenty
percent of the actual viewport width and
that'll just make the design a little
more responsive to different screen
sizes our design is already looking a
lot better but now let's go ahead and
add a few utility classes to distinguish
between different colors we can add this
class to any section to set the
background to that color now we're ready
to implement our first curve and to do
that i'm going to add an empty div below
the content with a class of curve
normally it's not a good practice to
have empty divs lying around but you
could add content inside of here if you
want it to sit on top of the curve
itself now this curve will be
implemented with plain css but i have to
warn you that this is the most difficult
example in this entire video don't get
discouraged if it seems too complicated
because the upcoming examples are way
easier to implement i'm demonstrating
this example primarily to show you that
it is possible to implement fairly
complex curves with nothing but css the
curve itself will have a position of
absolute and be placed at the bottom of
its parent div remember we set the
parent section element to position
relative which is important here because
it places the curve inside of the
section as opposed to the main body of
the page that gives us an empty div to
work with now we can target the before
and after pseudo elements which are
basically like invisible html elements
that we can target with our css and in
this example you can think of each one
as a circle that we will intersect
together to create the illusion of a
curve the content of the element will be
an empty string then it will have a
position of absolute then the
interesting thing is that it has a
border radius with two values if it was
just one value it would create a perfect
circle but when you add a second value
it creates an ellipse where the first
argument represents the vertical radius
and the second the horizontal radius
then after that we'll set its width and
height now at this point we can apply
the exact same styles to the after
element as well that'll give us two
circles to work with and now the tricky
part is getting them to line up properly
to look like a curve the first one will
be our dark circle and the after element
is the blue circle the tricky part is
putting the circles in the proper
location which will likely take a lot of
trial and error i'm using the transform
property along with translate which is
just a fancy way to say move the circle
to a different location the arguments to
translate represent the x and y axis the
final thing i'll do is on the after
element at z index negative one which
ensures the darker element will sit on
top of the lighter one let's go ahead
and open up the page in the browser and
the curve should now be visible if you
look closely you may notice that it's
not exactly perfect what you'll likely
need to do is open up the browser dev
tools and play with the values to move
them around until they get perfectly
aligned now another issue is that the
current implementation is causing the
content to overflow horizontally that's
not good but an easy way to fix the
problem is to set the overflow x
property to hidden on the parent element
that gets the job done but i think css
is more well suited for curves that have
a single ellipse or circle let's go back
down to the html and add a class of
bubble to one section and a class of
dark to another section we can easily
add a curve here by only targeting the
after pseudo element and giving it an
elliptical border radius on the top left
and top right followed by absolute
positioning to put it in the appropriate
location this example is very similar to
the last one in many ways but far more
simple i would definitely use css for
something like that but for more complex
curves let's take a look at how scalable
vector graphics or svg can simplify our
lives first let's go into our html and
add a class of red to one of the
sections the cool thing about svg is
that we can use a design tool or a
purpose-built web app like this one
called shape divider to automatically
draw the svg and provide the required
css to add it to the ui instantly
experiment with different settings to
get the design you're going for then
click the download button and copy that
html snippet it contains an svg graphic
that we can simply paste into the bottom
of one of our sections it has a div with
an automatically generated class name
which i'm going to change to wave just
to simplify things here from there we
can go back to the tool and copy the css
code paste that inside the style tags
then highlight the class name then right
click to change all the occurrences to
the wave class now if we go back to the
browser we have a wave that looks better
than the first one with far less effort
but now let's take things to the next
level by using yet another free tool
called hi-k this web app has a really
beautiful ui and is dedicated to
generating svg backgrounds automatically
i'm going to use the layered waves
option and put the waves on the top you
can tweak things here to look however
you want the only important thing here
is that you select colors that go with
the colors in your actual css code the
other thing i'm going to do here is
change the aspect ratio you can almost
think of this graphic as like a fancy
border or separator between content
sections so it needs to be long and
skinny make a note of that aspect ratio
because we're going to need it later
after you're happy with the appearance
go ahead and click the button to
download the file as an svg into your
project from there let's go into the css
and create a class called spacer we'll
use a relatively new css feature called
aspect ratio instead of trying to manage
the width and height of the element we
can use the aspect ratio property and
set it to whatever value we used for the
aspect ratio on the image then we'll use
the image as a background on whatever
element has this class the image should
take up the entire element so we'll set
background repeat to no repeat position
it in the center and give it a
background size of cover then we may
want to use this class multiple times so
i'm creating a second class that defines
the background image as the svg graphic
that we just downloaded from there we
can go down to the html and add an empty
div with these two classes in order to
apply that image as the transition
between two sections now again using an
empty div like this is sometimes
considered a bad practice but i do think
it's acceptable in this case and it's
definitely the easiest way to get the
job done the end result is this really
cool looking section with just a couple
of svg graphics and some css we can
really make this design stand out but
we're not done yet for the grand finale
we're going to bring in javascript to
create an animated morphing svg to
really make the web page come to life in
the html i'm adding a class of pink and
then adding those spacer layers on
either side of it and the top one has a
class of flip because we need that one
to do a 180. the flip class in the css
is just a utility that will rotate the
element by 180 degrees it should look
something like this but now let's add a
rotating blob right in the middle to
generate the blob i'll go back to the
high k app and create two random
graphics with the blob shape i've
downloaded them into the project but
what i actually need is the source code
from the raw svg file i'm taking the
code from one of the blobs and pasting
it down inside of the section what you
want to do next is right click and hit
format document so we can see all the
properties on it clearly inside the svg
code you'll notice a rect or rectangle
element go ahead and delete that one
what we're interested in is the path
which is the shape of the blob itself
that gives us one blob in the svg but we
actually want a second blob in there as
well so we're going to go into our other
blob and find the g element which means
group and go ahead and copy that element
from the raw svg code once copied go
back to the svg in the html and paste it
as the sibling to the other group i
realized that was very cumbersome and it
would be a lot easier if you used a
design tool like figma but that's beyond
the scope of this video at this point
you should see two blobs on top of each
other now in order to animate one blob
into the other we need to give each path
an id which we'll call blob one and blob
two now normally a morph animation is
pretty difficult to pull off but i
discovered this library called cute.js
or maybe kutejs not sure how to
pronounce it it feels kind of similar to
green sock if you've ever used an
animation library like that and to
install it all we have to do is add the
script tag for the cdn link to the head
of the document then down at the bottom
of the section we'll add a script that
references the global object cute with a
k and it's from 2 method
it'll use blob 1 as the starting svg and
then animate to the blob 2 svg and as a
final argument we can add an object with
some options on it like the duration
which will be 3000 milliseconds and also
the yoyo option which will have it go
back and forth between the two animation
states and lastly call animation start
and that's all it takes to create an svg
morphing animation with javascript just
a couple of other little points here we
need to make the second blob have a
visibility of hidden so it's not visible
when the animation first starts and then
i'm also going to add some basic
positioning css here to position the
blob directly underneath the main
content in that section the end result
is this beautiful curvaceous website i'm
gonna go ahead and wrap things up there
but if you like content like this
upgrade to a pro membership on fireship
io to get access to all of my premium
videos thanks for watching and i will
see you in the next one